you got a couple decades left are you
gonna ever run for president or be in
politics I mean we're looking at a
candidate who has a fraction of the
business success you have none of the
state's been like you know behavior none
of the vision none of the ability to get
people to work together and he's the
leading candidate and he's gonna win it
looks like I mean it's pretty disturbing
State of America that a reality TV star
can win and you're sitting here you've
done some of the greatest things in
business in the last couple of decades
why would you not go in there and try to
help well I mean Bloomberg did and will
actually be in politics run for office
why wouldn't you I respect people do
including Bloomberg and many others for
me I think the portfolio I have led by
revolution yeah case foundation and yang
this kind of behind the scenes you know
kind of bridge builder' on policy is a
great portfolio keeps me pretty busy
busy but don't you have a moral
obligation I'm doing my part
what do you are
I appreciate that you're very kind but
no I mean like I'm I like my like my
portfolio and I want to be you know a a
try and I worked with the President
Clinton I worked with President Bush and
I worked with President Obama I work
with whoever the next president is
hopefully if you take a cabinet position
if like somebody one like let's say
eventually you know yeah I'm focused on
what I'm doing I want that like if that
would be a pretty amazing thing I mean
you would be a great captain well you're
very kind but I think at this point what
you agency need to end this energy
because I don't like the direction it's
you know like the convincing this book
the only reason I say this is I have a
theory I have a theory right now which
is if you look at what this country
needs its entrepreneurship its
out-of-the-box thinking it's being able
to lead and the politicians we've all
grown these amazing business that was
the huge opportunity but we did such a
good job building these businesses
capital markets so efficient business is
growing so well you know the fact that
this little tiny country with 300
million people has all of the global
businesses out there and there's very
few you know truly global businesses
that were operate outside of their board
that are not American it's freezin was
that true that's not sure but we went
down the list of the top ten Internet
companies I mean how many can come out
of America I guess another by my guess
on the third wave you'll see my butt
wink both regional launch Birds within
the country and global on tradition I
agree that's the most innovative
entrepreneurship but I wouldn't get
complacent I wouldn't get cocky because
there is the government doesn't we don't
the government situation worked out
tell me actually maintained that you
need to run can we maintain the run
though did you think we can't maintain
the run but it's gonna be a challenge
you gotta get the government dialed in
we got to get the government dialed in
but we also need to get the folks in
places like this place to focus on these
issues and engage with the government
not just complain about it don't just
hire the problems jumpin brought Megan
Smith who by the way Megan Smith was
part of the green house or the green
house with some planet planet out planet
out which was the first LGBT 25 years
ago you guys back that we did back
though you took heat for that didn't you
at that time a little bit of heat for
backing a you know a gay enterprise in
the 90 it late 80s early 90s or whatever
that happened early 90s right thing to
do the right thing to do
all right listen everybody by the book
I'm saying it right now Steve cash for
president lastly no seriously I mean
it's just like it's like you Sheryl
Sandberg Mike Bloomberg you just look at
this I like the Sandberg Bloomberg
suggestions I would that would be I like
about promote those I like the Sandberg
case I think she would be a great
president or vice president you a great
present as president I don't know that's
a pretty powerful car Bloomberg said he
wouldn't do it did you ever run ending
this interview hang it down here looks
like what about the why did you talk to
Mike Bloomberg about running did you
give him like a push and say hey Mike I
talked about but yeah I'm not gonna say
what I yeah said but not and you know I
got great respect for him he would have
been so great if your air wouldn't have
been you would have loved it it would've
been the best candidate why didn't he do
it you think I don't think he thought
path to win he I think he said early on
that that depending on how that thing's
shaked up on both the Republican and
Democrat side he was open to it
but he concluded it sounds like a couple
months ago that there wasn't a path to
victory and so he said I'm not gonna do
something unless I think it's gonna work
and I don't think it's gonna work so oh
are you publicly part of either party No
so you're not publicly part of the party
you're an independent mmm independent